前一段時間我發了一條貼文
然後有一位網友的評論
讓我感到很有感觸
他用了普通人這三個字
透露出一絲無奈和淒涼的感覺
我們都知道
看問題的方式和角度
決定了一個人的人生
如果你總是以普通人自居的話
那麼你永遠是個普通人
怎樣才能夠從普通人陷阱當中
走出來
我認為最重要最根本的
就是改變你看世界的方式
今天我來講幾個我自己的小故事
希望這些故事能夠對你有啟發
我是1999年大學畢業
大學畢業以後我就留校做老師
當時我是在杭州
當時的工資只有900塊錢一個月人民幣
剛畢業的時候也沒有房
要麼自己租房子住
要麼就是住集體宿舍
那麼我選擇自己租房住
後來到了2000年的時候
中國的房地產商業化就逐漸展開了
那麼普通人是可以貸款買房了
我當時作為教師
可以獲得不少貸款的優惠
當時我是看中了一套房
在杭州的鼓樓地區
位置是非常好的
房價19萬首付5萬
然後每個月大概是900塊錢的月供
我當時手上的錢
基本上只夠付首付
其實真正的難度是在後面
是在月供上面
因為月供基本上等於我的工資了
那麼交完月供之後
我基本上就只能喝西北風了
我媽當時就說
這個房子太貴了
我們買不起
不過當然後來我還是買了
買不起是當時大多數普通人
當時的第一直覺反應
那麼我的反應就是說
我想提高自己的生活
我不想租房子了
我希望自己的生活上一個臺階
我可以用我的工資
去還月供
那麼我在想辦法
從業餘時間當中
去拓展一些收入渠道
我當時是在美術學院工作
那麼空餘的時間也是比較多的
我們美術學院的老師
基本上都在想辦法掙錢
其實我在讀大學的過程當中
其實就一直在做一些商業項目
因為那個時候剛好趕上了
中國的房地產
慢慢起步的這樣的一個浪潮
所以說我認為
我是有能力
可以掙到這個錢來還房貸的
那麼為了還房貸
那麼我也擴大了
我自己的設計工作室
招了人
成立了公司
那麼項目也是越做越大
那麼我的第一桶金
就是來自於我自己做設計公司
買了這個房之後
2010年
我辭職
離開杭州去上海發展的時候
我這套房已經漲了10倍
這個故事我想表達的是
我們不能夠被自己的
當前的狀態
限制住了自己的想象力
而是要用想象力
去拓展自己的能力圈
去開發自己的潛力
如果我不是想提升自己
的生活水平
我就不會去想買這個房
當時買房
還是有風險
對不對
有很多事情
你不知道未來會怎樣
當時的房對很多普通人來說
也都是負擔不起的
如果不是因為買這個房
那麼我也就不會去開這個公司
我不會有這個公司
就不會有我的第一桶金
對不對
那麼有了第一桶金
有了一定的資本之後
那麼我需要更廣泛的自由
所以後來才會從零開始
學習投資
然後再一步一步
現在移民到海外
那麼我現在自己的生活
簡單來說就是四個字
叫做自由富足
這一切
其實都是源於當初的一個想法
說到底
我不想做個普通人
如果你也有同樣的想法
我下面再講幾個小故事
希望對你有啟發
我讀大學本科時候
學的是環境藝術設計
研究生讀的是纖維藝術
它是雕塑藝術下面的一個研究方向
前面我說了
我的第一桶金
是來自於我的本專業是設計
但是我在2010年以後的生活和發展
就全部都是靠投資了
但是不管怎麼說
一個學藝術的人
跨界到了金融領域
那麼對於普通人來說
這是一個非常大的跨越
我是怎樣實現這種跨越的
我認為首先就是
要拓展自己的知識結構
1995年到2000年左右
中國大陸的房地產市場逐漸商業化
那麼對建築對環境設計的需求
是非常大的
那麼我這個專業
在當時算是一個
恰好趕上了好時代
所以我很早就接觸到這些
商業領域
那麼我對商業
對創業
對經濟方面的這些內容
也都是非常的感興趣
這就使得我的知識結構
很自然的
從藝術設計這種美學框架
逐漸就拓展到了
更廣泛的商業領域
我很早就訂閱了
像華爾街日報
經濟學人
這些著名的媒體
那個時候在中國不需要翻牆
就可以看得到這些東西的
就是到了2003年以後
這個就越來越難了
那就不得不翻牆了
為了看這些內容
就沒辦法
就搞懂了翻牆
對吧
然後搞懂了
怎樣使用國際信用卡支付
還順便知道了
那裡有一個美國的股票市場
然後當我發現了美股這個
大金礦以後
我就開始想辦法
把資金移出海外
更重要的是就是
做這些事情
讓我逐漸有了這種國際的視野
翻牆出來
最開始是用翻譯軟件看英文
那麼後來久而久之
英文水平也有了一定的提高
那麼英文水平提高以後
又讓這個視野
更加的打開了
那麼在知識結構
有了一定的擴展之後
就有了
拓展自己朋友圈的
這樣的一個願望
有一句話說的是
你的五個朋友
決定了你的認知水平
如果你身邊的人
都喜歡刷短視頻
喜歡聊八卦
那麼你很難接觸到
所謂的這種破壞性創新
或者說資本偏好這一類話題
所以說
拓展朋友圈是非常必要的
如果說你對投資感興趣
就應該儘可能的多結交
這種投資圈創業圈的朋友
當然了
在現實生活當中
普通人要想跨越自己的階層
或者說跨越自己的圈子
去別人的圈子
去有錢人的圈子
那是相當不容易的
但是現在網絡這麼發達
一些有意思的這種論壇
股東會
什麼大師課之類的
我認為是有必要去學一學
去看一看的
那麼如果說有投資方面的圈子
也可以結識到一些牛人
我記得以前我在上海的時候
那個時候雪球
每年會舉行一個雪球大會
在大會上面
也會認識到一些投資圈的朋友
那麼還有一段就是說有一些
投資圈的大咖
開的社群
我認為也是可以參與的
當然了
大多數的好東西都是要付費的
而且並不便宜
總而言之
我認為找一個靠譜的圈子
帶著問題
去找答案
看看有沒有人能解決你的問題
如果沒有
那就再換一個圈子
有時候
某一個人的一句話
可以改變你的人生
接下去我還有一個小故事
專門講這件事情
學會提問
這是最快的學習方式
是進步最快的學習方式
不要以為付費的內容都是割韭菜
是吧
購買付費的內容
反正你就帶著你的思想
帶著你的問題
進去
打開話匣子
說完你的問題
看誰能幫你解決
解決完了也走
不解決也走
對不對
那麼我自己的購買這些付費內容
我有一個經驗
就是說
我從來不買那種付年費
年費看上去便宜
但實際上
有一種不舒服的感覺
我寧可貴一點
我也願意
一個月一個月的付
不滿意我隨時可以走
我沒有多大損失
那麼感覺好的話
我隨時也可以再回來
我的自己的社群
我也是取消了年費
你願意進來
隨時來都可以
你有什麼話題
我們可以聊
聊完你走
最核心的一點
就是你想得到什麼
有一個觀念
就是說叫做第一性原則
用第一性原則來思考問題
會讓你的人生變得非常的簡單
我做投資
從設計跨界到了做投資
那麼我的主要目的
並不是賺更多的錢
因為在當時
我的業務非常好
我的設計公司項目做不完
如果我想賺更多的錢
我只需要僱傭更多的人
把公司規模搞大
就可以了
對吧
賺錢的思路
但是我發現這種生意模式
無法降低邊際成本
越做大
人就越多
人越多越難管理
越難管理
最後就形成了一個死循環
雖然可以賺很多錢
但是它不是一種
看得見的指數級的增長
所以說
我希望是用
錢來賺錢
賺最容易賺到的錢
這是我的第一性原則
我可以接受
資本增長的速度慢一點
但是我希望它能夠自己成長
不需要我付出額外的努力
在我睡覺的時候
它也能夠增長
這是對我來說
我反覆在思考的一件事情
那麼我這兩年
在網絡上分享的一個
Hi5 組合
一個投資組合
它就是符合我的第一性原理
解決問題的這種方案
我分享這個組合
就是想用實例
來告訴所有人
這是普通人
積累財富最快最簡單的路徑
你不相信？
我就做給你看
這就是我為什麼要公開這件事情
我把所有的詳細記錄
都公佈在網上
在下面這個網址
你就可以找得到
我做了11年的大學老師
我是有那麼一點點
傳教士精神的
我就是喜歡
把我認為好的東西
傳播給更多的人
我享受這個過程
進一步說
第一性原理
簡單來說
如果放在每個人身上
你思考一下
如果說你的目標
是獲得職位升遷
通過加班努力是沒有出路的
你需要為你的公司
解決更大的問題
創造更大的價值
提升你在公司當中的重要性
那麼自然你的地位就會得到提升
對不對
那麼如果說你的目的
你的目標是賺更多的錢
那麼
靠別人去推薦幾支牛股給你
是沒有前途的
你要知道沒有牛股會一直漲
它的波動的過程當中
是會讓你非常痛苦的
所以說你要用一種策略
或者說是
用槓桿的方式去放大收益
這些內容
在我的YouTube頻道
你都可以找得到
總而言之
想清楚你要什麼
然後根據目標
去設計你的路徑
這才是解決問題的
正確的姿勢
前面我也說了
就是說
我發現我做設計公司
商業模式
不符合我的第一性原理
但是我當時
並不知道怎樣去解決
對吧
那麼但是這個思考
一直在我的腦海裡頭轉
直到有一次
機緣巧合
在2004年
我做了一個
湖北武漢的一個設計項目
當時設計項目的老闆
後來我知道
他是一個
當年在杭州
做商品期貨的一個高手
我和老闆
老闆姓余
我們就叫余總
余總
我跟他有一次
因為設計上面的一些觀念的衝突
發生了一次很激烈的爭吵
那麼在這一次爭吵當中
余總有一段話
對我的衝擊是非常大的
大概的意思就是說
他說
你們這些學藝術的人
學設計的人
有點自以為是
自以為清高
自以為自己很優秀很特別
但是我告訴你
我選你來做這個項目
不是因為你優秀你特別
而是因為我不想再花更多的時間
去挑選別人了
你還行
所以用你
對於我來說
用你和用別人沒差別
你們只是我實現目標的工具而已
你能想象我當時的心情嗎
不過因為
我當時一直在思考
我怎麼樣去解決我這個問題
第一性原理的問題
所以我當時並沒有去跟他去
去爆發
所以我還是耐下心思
聽他說
說完以後
我把我的
我在腦海裡想的這些顧慮
這些問題
說出來
我說
余總
我碰到了這樣的問題
給我出點主意
然後就是這樣的一次談話之後
余總為我解開了我的疑惑
讓我明白
投資是符合我的第一性思考
後來我就開設了人生當中的
第一個投資賬戶
是一個期貨賬戶
也正是這一次機緣巧合
我就非常幸運的
在中國的銅期貨的大牛市當中
賺到了人生的第二桶金
第一桶金是我的設計
做設計公司
那麼第二桶金就是用
我做設計賺來的錢
放到資本市場
放大
成為了我的第二桶金
也是受到余總的影響
那麼我做投資的起點是非常高的
我並沒有大多數人的這種散戶思維
那麼我投入的金額是比較大的
投入的時間也是非常多的
甚至後來我把公司逐漸的脫手
我專心來做投資
我想說的是
如果說有人對你說的話非常的刺耳
你可能碰上貴人了
那是你成長的機會
這年頭大家都很忙的
沒有人願意在你身上多花一分錢時間的
對不對
那麼如果說有人願意在你身上花時間
願意對我說壞話
有人願意在我的評論區留言
這都是非常好的東西
我一直認為
黑粉才是死忠粉
他們對我的批評都是非常好的
我是非常在意的
雖然我事後可以把他們拉黑
但是我絕對不會忽視他們的建議的
總而言之
我們不能只看跟自己觀念相同的
跟自己觀念相一致的觀點
思維的碰撞
有些人從反方向來觀察你
他提出你的弱點
這是非常好的
對不對
思維的碰撞比認同更有價值
那麼我自己在性格上面也有一個特點
就是說
我不會把一件事情想到百分之百再去做
我差不多想到百分之六七十
感覺模糊正確了
那麼我就會去做
那麼我們經常會聽到這樣的一種說法
說等我有了錢
我就去移民
我就去全職投資
blah blah blah
這種句式其實是把條件看得比目標更重要
言下之意就是說
如果說沒有錢
那我就放棄這個目標
我就放棄這個目的
那麼我可以毫不客氣的說
凡是用這種套路說話的人
最終都是無法達成目標的
我的人生只有一個目標
就是更廣泛的自由
和更高品質的生活
這兩件事情是相輔相成的
如果說沒有自由
就談不上什麼高品質的生活
所以我把這兩個目標合二為一
變成一個目標
所以我所有的人生歷程
人生經歷
所有的坎坷
成功
快樂
痛苦
都是我希望是朝著目標方向前進的
聽上去好像很寬泛
但其實執行起來非常簡單
每當我要做任何選擇的時候
或者說要花錢
或者說是要付出精力等等
我都會思考一下
我做這件事情
會不會讓我變得更自由
會不會讓我的生活
提高一個檔次
或者說朝著我想要的方向發展
如果答案是
那我就去做
不論多大的代價
我都會去做
如果說是否定的
那就不做
很簡單
我認為
去到目標的過程
比結果更重要
人生就是上臺階
一臺階一臺階往上走
很多時候你也只能是
走一步看一步
但是目標
必須是非常清晰的
至少那個方向
必須是非常清晰
我希望我的每一步
都更接近目標
或者說每一步都是
朝著模糊正確的方向在走
那麼這個過程就是快樂的
東拉西扯說了這麼多
我就想說
如果說
你想過得跟普通人不一樣
你不想做個普通人
那麼首先
想辦法去擴展自己的認知
然後擴展自己的圈子
最重要的是
搞清楚你想要什麼
有一些人
有一些事讓你不舒服
你要注意
它有可能會改變你的人生
總而言之
一定要讓你的目標
你的方向非常的明確
讓每一次的選擇
更接近目標
對吧
好
那麼就說這些
我的故事
希望對你有啟發